we are talking about climate change
carbon emissions
and global warming and various other
aspects
but we are not addressing soil
soil is the habitat upon which zillions
of lives thrive
once there is no richness in soil then
you have forsaken the planet in many
ways
every responsible scientist in the world
and the un agencies are clearly saying
we have only 80 to 100 harvests left
that means approximately 45 to 50 years
of agricultural soil left on the planet
by 2045
we will be producing 40 percent less
food than what we are producing right
now and our populations will be 9.3
billion people the food shortages that
could manifest in the next 25 years
the consequences of that is unimaginable
civil wars will unfold across the world
once there is food shortage
what we are facing now is soil
extinction
why is soil becoming extinct
where is it going away what is happening
to our soil
we must understand
if you add
organic content to sand
sand will turn into soil
if you remove all organic content from
the soil soil will become sand in normal
agricultural soil the minimum organic
content should be between three to six
percent the most minimum is three
percent at least this minimum to keep
the soil alive to keep the soil as
living soil is a must agricultural soils
across the world the depletion is so
heavy in most countries more than 50
percent of the topsoil is already gone
in the last hundred years
the nutrient levels have dropped
significantly the level of
micronutrients you would get from your
food in early 20th century to what you
are getting from the same food now has
dropped 90 percent if you ate one orange
in 1920s what you got from it
now in 2020 if you have to get the same
you will have to eat eight oranges this
is what we have done to our food
soil is the biggest ecosystem on the
planet
and so few people know anything about it
one teaspoon of healthy soil probably
contains more microbes than there are
people on earth the microbial life in
the first 12 to 15 inches of topsoil
is the basis of our existence it is this
magic beneath our feet which has
produced the life that we are
this first 12 to 15 inches of soil
is the basis
of life for 87 of life on this planet
including you and me
we have to begin to recognize that
what we call our soil mother earth
is a living organism
open soils
ripped open by plowing open to sunlight
is the basis of destruction of microbial
life so the focus should be in
agriculture the focus should be on
seeing that
land is under shade as much as possible
some kind of shade
grasses herbs bushes
trees
conscious planet is launching safe soil
movement
to bring about a policy change to
regenerate soil as a part of this
i'm 65 and i'm riding 30 000 kilometers
a lone motorcycle journey 30 000
kilometers across 24 nations
to activate support from the citizenry
to assure the government's long-term
investments will be appreciated so it's
extremely important
that
soil regeneration is enshrined in the
policy of every garment on the planet we
must change the narrative on the planet
that
soil
is a wealth
a legacy we have received from previous
generations and we have to pass it on as
living soil for future generations we
are in a cusp of time if you do the
right things now
in the next 15 to 25 years we can
significantly turn this situation around
and regenerate the soil but if we allow
this to progress like this for another
30 to 40 years after 40 years if we
attempt this
then it could take 150 to 200 years
because that much loss of biodiversity
would have happened
from 21st of march for 100 days
the whole world every human being on the
planet should talk soil we must hear the
word soil save soil everywhere to see
that the narrative on the planet changes
towards the most vital aspect of our
life the soil each one of you should
reach as many people as you can to make
this happen many global leaders and
influencers are already participating in
the moment be a part of this and let us
make it happen
from my part
as much as i can contribute we're going
to save the soil do your part and saving
the soils our future our children's
future
and our planet's future
depend on it save the soil we know what
we must do
so let's make it happen let's make it
happen let's make it happen
let's make it happen let's make it
happen
[Music]
everybody says okay what can i do shall
i go and fix my garden
see you fixing your garden is very cute
of you all right
but it is not a solution
it's very nice you must do it it's a
wonderful thing to do but it is not a
solution for the world
because 71 percent of the world's land
is under till
that's what needs to change if a real
difference has to happen
for that to happen unless it's enshrined
in the policy
it will not happen
and even if it happens next generation
can just reverse it as we have done it
hello
it has to be in the policy how in urban
land there are building policies all
right you can only build that much if
you build more
it will be demolished
yes or no
but if you have 10 acres of land you can
plow every inch of it
and in 10 15 years time you can turn it
into a desert nobody will ask you why
have you done it
because
destroying soil is not considered a
crime
but this is the worst crime you can
commit because
you are eating up the food of the unborn
child already
and it's very very important to
understand that soil is not our property
it's a legacy we have received from
previous generations it's our basic
responsibility as a generation to pass
it on as a living soil for next
generation that is something we must do
for this to happen minimum three to six
percent organic content should be there
in the soil that must become the policy
in every nation how do we do it the
nations will have to provide incentives
right now we are saying 1.48 is the
approximate
organic content in these countries
if you if the government offers an
incentive if a farmer makes it 3
he will get this much if he can do it in
two or three years time if he makes it
six percent he will get more like this
they can set up incentive apart from
that you can also brand your products
like this
that if you're organ if your farm is six
percent organic content instead of
saying the product is organic which
doesn't mean anything actually it's just
a branding
if you say
my land as a farm has six percent
organic content if that is marked on the
product you can also price it higher and
people will buy it because it's coming
from a very rich soil
if you
if you raise the organic content in a
given land to eight to ten percent
your irrigation requirement will come
down to thirty percent of what you're
using right now if you're using 100
liters of water you can do the same work
with 30 liters of water and you can
brush your teeth every day
hello
[Applause]
if you
if you raise the organic content to 12
to 15 percent
which will take some time in most lands
if you do that your irrigation
requirement will come down to 10 to 15
percent that is hundred liters will
become 15 liters of water
that is saving water hello
that is real change above all if that
moisture is there in the soil
life will thrive
because the microbial life needs organic
content and moisture for them to thrive
if moisture is if organic content is
there moisture is held in the soil if
you're going to forest to any of you
because you they say you have a lot of
forest what kind is it evergreen is it
all kinds
then you have not seen all forest lands
in the world
in this latitude you can't have all
kinds of forests
if you have let's say you have good
forest because the bees are doing well
means there must be substantial
vegetation
so if you go into your forest you don't
need any pickaxe just with your fingers
if you dig like this three inches if you
go it will be damp
that means there is enough organic
content that is why water is held there
even if it doesn't rain for three months
still it will be wet
that is how agricultural soil should
become
then you grow food which will nourish
you then you grow food which will be
immunity for you for many things for
example right now the world has been
reeling under this pandemic
i don't know how bad he's been in
slovenia
how bad
not ready
i see
only a few of you are wearing masks
because yesterday i was in vienna
everybody was measuring mats with
yesterday the case load was something
like 50 000 per day
so uh in the country
so they were all wearing no it's okay
he's already got it so what can we do
so
i'm saying
you don't need some expert virologist to
tell this to you any simple doctor will
tell you
if there is not enough vitamin a vitamin
b6 vitamin b12 vitamin c
calcium iron foliate
magnesium zinc
in the diet that you're eating
you become susceptible to upper
respiratory tract infections this is a
well-known fact
whatever you call this appendama
coronavirus number 19 20 21 whatever you
want to call it you call it what you
want essentially it is a respiratory
tract infection all right
if your nutrient value was good
your ability to resist it would be much
better unfortunately we've lost over 6
million people across the world almost
everybody that i know has lost some has
lost somebody who's dear to them you
know
this is because the nutritional value is
very low i'm not saying there wouldn't
be a pandemic if the nutrition was good
definitely there wouldn't be such a high
toll
for sure
and today there is substantial studies
to show
that
mental illnesses in the world and
nutritional micronutrient quality in the
food that you eat are very directly
connected
if you're feeling a little wonky maybe
you're not eating the right kind of food
you know
so
today why is talking about mental
illness pandemic
see pandemic means if one person has it
here in this hall all of us become
susceptible that's a pandemic
when we say mental illness pandemic that
means all of us are susceptible to lose
our minds today or tomorrow
that's what it means now they're talking
about a suicide pandemic
in the year 2020
more people committed suicide in japan
than the number of people who died of
the pandemic
so we don't really need the virus we are
pretty good my question is you've
mentioned that trees are
a part of
preventing the soil to
go away uh so what can we do about
deforestation here in slovenia
um we have a lot of forests as you know
but um they're cutting trees in cities
uh they're building
a lot of
residential areas over there
and is there any way that we can
approach this problem
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
see
everybody wants all the comforts and
conveniences
but at the same time
we don't want to do certain things life
doesn't work like that see right now
could we have held this meeting
under a tree
if it was india we would have done it
because the weather would permit it
here we need a hall
well how many trees did they cut to
build this building they would have cut
something definitely
can't help it
we can minimize it we cannot avoid it so
let's let's understand this
let's not always this is not something
to be dealt with emotionally this needs
to be
done very pragmatically otherwise
believe me if you put economy and
development versus ecology and trees and
stuff
ecology will lose
it's very important we must design it in
such a way both of them can thrive
together otherwise
people will talk ecology
but vote for economy
yes or no
everywhere in the world not just here
that's a fact
so one important thing that i have been
doing when i was at the un i told them
my work is to officiate the marriage of
economy and ecology
because if these two things don't get
together and work together simply it
won't work for example in the kaveh
recalling region in the kaveri region
we've done this
see the farmer's income has gone up 300
to 800 percent in seven to eight years
and those of them who gone for a certain
level of trees
once in 12 years when they fell these
trees
they're getting about the same money
they would get if they sell the land
so every 12 years they can sell the land
and still keep the land
it's a good deal isn't it
you sold the land but still you have the
land with you
because they cut the trees and sold it
for this is important that we understand
how
we balance this i am not saying just
blatantly do wild kind of development no
but what is needed may have to be done
otherwise people
there is populations to serve isn't it
human beings have gotten used to a
certain level of comfort and convenience
you can't tell them go live in the
jungle
they won't do that
they will talk about it they will
appreciate it on the phone screen they
like rain forest
if you leave them in rain forest for one
week they don't know
what will happen to them when i lived in
the jungles and after two three weeks
when i come home even my mother wouldn't
recognize me head to toe insect bites
because i slept on the trees and here
and there
and i'm bitten head to toe all right
you can't even recognize me i would be
like that it'll take three four times
two days to get back to my shape
of my features back
so
you're not ready for that kind of life
we've gotten used to certain comfort and
convenience today
and people are not willing to go back
to that kind of life which people lived
you will see
uh
you know people
even in villages today there is too much
comfort but you will see
already at least in the movies if you
see
people are like this because
all the time something will be itching
if you live in the
natural conditions believe me
you will be bitten head to toe with all
kinds of things you must just get used
to it
because you can't avoid them you don't
know where they are
even today our center in united states
in tennessee
we are nearly 17 square miles of land or
over 20 000 acres
we have committed 70 percent to
conservation
we will keep the forest as it is 70 of
the land 30 we will build
but if you enter the forest in the
summer season you had it
you had it means you had it the ticks
are waiting up there they will sense
your body temperature and
they'll shoot you won't know where they
landed they will go and embed in the
skin
after two months that guy is crawling
out of my belly
you know i am
this guy he's gotten into me when i'm in
united states i'm in india for about one
and a half months
after that i'm sleeping in the night
something itching and do this something
on my stomach then i pull out this
living guy
he traveled all the way from united
states to india with me
they're like that
so
don't romanticize too much it's very
important we handle this pragmatically
the way it is needed for today's life
so our aspirations need to be
modulated in such a way but at the same
time not against everything that needs
to develop in a country if you oppose
they will beat you down and destroy all
the forests don't do that make forest an
attractive place where children can go
and you know explore there is a love for
the land this must come in the next
generation that they enjoy being there
otherwise you can't preserve it for long
i'm i appreciate the emotion behind it
but it needs to be dealt with
pragmatically and uh well
we need to make the governments commit
at least a certain amount of forest will
never be disturbed
we must make them commit that but in the
city if you can't do development
then people will complain
they want roads they want buildings they
want conveniences they want schools they
want hospitals hello
people need all this
we must understand
if you
add
organic content to sand
sand will turn into soil
if you remove all organic content from
the soil soil will become sand in normal
agricultural soil the minimum organic
content should be between three to six
percent the most minimum is three
percent at least this minimum to keep
the soil alive
to keep the soil as living soil i think
the three percent minimum is something
i've been pushing for the last 40 years
so
i've been causing trouble for a while
three percent is is kind of the the
borderline where you've got enough
diversity in the kinds of foods that are
present so that all of the necessary
sets of
microorganisms will be able to
perform their jobs at the right time and
in the right place and people don't
think about the fact that every growing
season is different from every other
growing season you've ever encountered
it's hot or cold or wet or dry or some
combination of different abiotic factors
how much sand salt clay do you have how
available
is
are those nutrients tied in the sand
silts and clays for your microorganisms
to be able to pull them out
you've got to have all of that diversity
of food if a soil is a living entity
which i teach and i believe and i have
written about it
in fact i'm planning to write a book on
rites of soil i wrote an article on
writing so i'm planning to write a book
on writer so every living thing has a
right
um
so if a soil is a living thing uh it
must have rights
uh
butterfly monarch butterfly has right uh
bard eagle has right uh
panda have you know one wildlife
fund organization they made panda is a
living thing and it has their for rights
um
sometimes i forgot uh that we forgot
that human also have rights many places
unfortunately they don't
um so
soil definitely have rights
so like any other living thing soil has
a right to be protected
to be restored
to be managed judiciously
to thrive
and to support life processes
so that living things on it
are very well supported
science has now proven that we have more
than 7 million life farms
and most of that
is in soil
most of it
and we must protect we must
restore we must enhance
we must do whatever we can
that that life in soil and soils ability
to support life is not destroyed
so destroying a soil is a crime against
nature
and we are part of nature
therefore it's also crime against us
there's a very strong link between
soil degradation
and global issues
for example um
climate change
soil since the beginning of agriculture
about ten thousand years ago
civilization
was about 2500 3500 bc
it banished about 1200 bc
because of climate change
that region had a rainfall of about 1000
millimeter
when the height of indus civilization
the rainfall decreed to about 250 300
millimeter which it is even now
that is when the indus valley
civilization managed
many other civilizations in the world
closer to united states as the king
caused maya
they also perished because they did not
take care of the soil under their feet
so
current civilization i call it carbon
civilization
everything we do is based on carbon
fossil fuel based carbon
and therefore we have depleted
also carbon not only from fossil fuel
but also from soil
soil to one meter depth
contains 1500 giga ton
15 1550 to be exact giga ton of organic
carbon to one meter depth
to also take inorganic carbon in soil
carbonates bicarbonate to one meter
depth is 950 gigahertz
so together to one meter depth soils of
the world
the permafrost free soil so all which
are not frozen
those soil
contain about 2500 giga ton of
carbon in the atmosphere at the moment
it's about 880 gigaton so soiled up
three times
all the trees and all the vegetation of
the world has
560
gigatons so soil has four times those
if you combine the dead biomass into the
soil the trees which are have been done
for a long time and are preserved
together the dead living biomass
in the vegetation is 620
so if you combine atmosphere 880
plus 620
that is about 1500 giga ton
that is still much less than 2500 giga
ton
so if we change
carbon stock and soil of the world by
one giga ton
apply it burn it
uh deplete it erode it emitted in the
atmosphere it will increase co2 in the
atmosphere by approximately 0.5
parts per million
but if we can take carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere through plants and put it
back to the soil and keep it there
then we deplete the carbon from the
atmosphere and make
global warming
lesser
serious problem so between 2020 and 2100
several of us my colleague about 15
including some from india china
south america
europe of course u.s
we estimated that if we manage this all
properly
we can put in the soil about 180 giga
ton of carbon in soil
if we manage all properly
in addition
if we manage vegetation properly trees
and
station
we can put another 150 160 giga ton of
carbon in the trees
between now
and 2020
that together is 330 giga ton of carbon
which translates into drawdown of
atmospheric carbon dioxide
155 parts per million i hear people
saying
that in tamil nadu
farming has been happening for over 12
000 years
probably the longest anywhere in the
world
we are still plowing the same land
and for all this millennia it fed us
but now in two generations
we have brought it to a place
where all the studies are showing
nearly 25 of the land agriculture land
in india is on the verge of becoming a
desert
becoming a desert means this
for any land
to be considered
as soil
there must be a minimum of two percent
organic content
in many states especially like punjab
and haryana
the organic content has come down
to point zero five percent
not point five point zero five percent
this means it's on the verge of becoming
a desert
that means you cannot grow a thing
in it in the next five to ten years it
may happen
why is such a thing happening
see in one acre of land
let us say to 10 tons came out of it
what you have taken out is not sugar
cane what you have taken out is top soil
so on an average
in this country
year on year
5.3 billion tons of topsoil is taken
away in the form of crop
this is nearly one millimeter
how much are we putting back
what we are putting back is negligible
how do we put back
organic content from where does it come
either you must have trees
which will shed leaves
or you must have animal waste
lots of animals and the waste
will become organic content
trees are already gone
animals are all traveling out in the
form of meat
when you export
meat
you must understand you are not sending
meat you are giving away india's top
soil
i want you to do some simple arithmetic
and tell me in how many years
will we become a total desert
the greatest achievement we have in our
country is
that
without any
great infrastructure
without any scientific knowledge
without
much financial support
just with traditional wisdom
and blood and sweat
our farmers are producing food for over
a billion people this is the greatest
achievement in the country
but today
we are pushing the farming community
to a place
where they have to take their own life
there are many reasons for this
but we should not forget
one fundamental reason is they are
working with
not so productive land
not enough water my question is how to
motivate young people to
do this movement how they are motivated
to go for example to the gym and pull
the weights you know
at least some of them
[Laughter]
they've given me a list of things you
could do
one thing is uh you follow this journey
for say on safe soil on instagram
facebook twitter and youtube
because
so this is because
all these numbers how many people say
safe soil in the next
91 days is going to be aggregated i am
addressing
cop
15 in ivory coast
on 9th and 10th of may
170 nations
their representatives will be there
and unccd is the host for the cop
and i'm addressing the whole group
by then if you have
over three billion people for me on this
various uh you know platforms it's a
done thing
[Applause]
so
one thing is uh
share the
safesoil.org website with as many people
as you can especially the the six seven
minute videos there
which i think they played in the
beginning
uh you can share that with as many
people as possible don't limit this to
slovenia croatia
and other things this has to be global
because when it comes to ecology and
soil national boundaries mean nothing
only
only we
human beings have this problem only we
human beings have this problem
that we cut up the planet into different
pieces and say this is mine and that is
yours and
every day we are fighting about it
nonstop
if if we have no piece of land to fight
about we will fight about our skin color
or we'll fight about some nonsense that
we believe in
race religion nationality has taken
enough lives
[Applause]
so this has happened because we
continuously focusing on
what is the differences between us we
are aiming at what are differences
between us
all kinds of things hair color they are
fighting can you beat it anybody can
change the damn hair color anytime these
days but on that some people are
fighting there are groups of people in
america fighting constantly on the
social media my hair color versus yours
you can go to a saloon and change the
damn hair color tomorrow morning
but about that they're fighting
so i'm saying we are always looking at
what is different about us
we need to look for common factors
the common denominator for all of us if
you don't understand what is the
unifying
cosmic consciousness if you don't know
where the hell that is at least you
understand our very bodies have come
from the soil we nourish ourselves from
the soil at least when we are dead we go
back to the soil
the question is only
the the question is only
whether you get it now or you will get
it when you're buried that's the only
question you'll anyway get it one day
but if you get it now we can make a
difference so let us look at the common
factors that unify us i don't want this
say you know it's under the umbrella of
conscious planet so this we are not
going to stop with ecology once the
necessary policy changes are achieved
which i'm confident in the next 18 to 24
months in most nations it will happen
it's just that we want to give
confidence for the governments that the
people are with you otherwise they will
hesitate and drag their feet about it
why i am saying this is
even in cop 26 they did not address soil
at all
simply because
they are afraid whether people will come
with them or not
so you have to show that people are with
you if you do this we are with you if
you give that confidence democratically
elected nations will move forward i want
you to understand i know everybody has
commentary about political leaders in
the world but i want you to understand
this if you had a profession where you
are in the top job and tomorrow morning
if you lose your election today tomorrow
morning you are nothing
if you had a job like that you would
also do a few crazy things
yes or no
so let's be
let's understand the problem that is
there without people's mandate they will
not move
so this is what needs to happen three to
four billion people have to speak they
don't have to support me your uh
youth friends who are pulling weights
they don't have to support me they just
have to say something about soil for
these 90 days if you do this
getting the policy done is very much
possible we have made these policy
documents for each nation separately
will be offering the policy document to
your leadership here and every all the
192 countries we have made separate
documents for every one of them it will
be offered to every nation more than
anything we will push it through the u.n
and it will go through it is just that
if it has space is important at what
speed it happens in given country
that speed can be achieved only if
people speak
otherwise governments will make the
policy and still hesitate to invest
money on that people should give the
confidence
if you invest money for the well-being
of the future generations we are with
you you need to say that see right now
if you have a child how many of you have
children you're of your own
if you
if you spend on your child
something that you could buy doesn't
happen isn't it so this is the economy
of the family hello
to put the child in a good school
you will forego something instead of
buying a fancy car you put the child in
a university
have you not done this every one of you
hello one way or the other
so this is the way it is if a nation
invests in future generations we may
have to forgo something you have to give
this confidence to the government that
if you invest on long-term well-being of
our nation we are with you
this is all i'm asking
save soil means just this you're giving
confidence to democratically elected
leaders that if they invest long term
you are with them
if they don't invest everything that
they have within this four or five years
that they are ruling you will dismantle
them this is the threat always from the
populations yes in every country this is
the problem so give them that confidence
we will see that it happens
and
and also the same soil song
make it reverberate across the country
ah this should become the your mantra
for the next 90 days at least you can
download this from the this thing there
is a qr code you can download that and
in india
the asia home school children took up
this commitment that they will inspire
10 million children across the country
to write a letter to the prime minister
you for your population at least hundred
two hundred thousand children if they
write to your prime minister you think
they will ignore this they cannot ignore
this i'm telling you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
home
[Music]
ah
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see the
one-on-one i did about karma with
sadguru check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there this is
like
banging your head on a wall which is not
going to break anyway it's your head
which will break what you can change you
do not change what you can craft you do
not do it because all your energy goes
into